ils étaient une centaine à s'être
rassemblés devant l'hôtel de ville pour
protester contre la réforme de
l'assurance chômage
c'est le vendredi de la colère
différents corps de métiers étaient à
présent notamment les intermittents de
l'emploi saisonnier les maîtres d'hôtel
elle est serveur les guides
conférenciers des restaurateurs
également des intermittents du spectacle
ils disent être lé grand oublié de cette
crise sanitaire et n'ont aucune
perspective d'avenir je vous propose
d'écouter leurs témoignages
on est là debout en tant qu'extra maître
d'hôtel de la restauration
événementielle pour se battre justement
tous ensemble pourquoi se regroupent
tous ensemble pour montrer que bon on
n'est pas d'accord avec cette réforme
aujourd'hui en fait on est des oubliés
on est en train de mourir de faim on est
en train de mettre notre famille par
terre tout ça parce que
parce qu on nous entend pas
l'interaction humaine les rencontres le
savoir faire notre travail en soi de
services donc vraiment tout ça ça manque
c'est vraiment une dynamique qui manque
pour le moment le gouvernement n'a
annoncé aucune date concernant la
potentielle réouverture de musées
d'hôtels et des restaurants ce n'est pas
la première fois qu'ils se mobilisent
pour faire entendre leur voix
d'autres mobilisations sont à venir dans
les prochaines semaines